hey guys how's it going so halloween is
coming up very very shortly and Jenna
and I decided well actually I decided
that I was gonna make some some
decorated sugar cookies and she was
gonna help me so here we are here we are
so we've got some things in front of us
we've got some cookie icing we've got
some cookie decorating things okay and
you've got copious nice did you make
these actually Francesca dude nice
they're probably of the perfect texture
okay let's flip these up is there a
theme to these cookies Halloween spooky
boo spooky and folks know where to go
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute hey hey I didn't even get a
chance to go start the game started what
a game is data Oh God I will use these
things figure out does this even work
looks like a pumpkin I think I'm gonna
make Frankenstein cool okay that looks
like a pumpkin to me these are all
terrible yeah I can't work under these
conditions
I'm so sorry he's conditionally I'm so
sorry Betty Crocker
oh this isn't work oh I'm so sorry Sara
Fields is that hurt that was either name
oh yeah the cookie well now this just
looks funny because I don't have the
bottom tip ah do you have a small white
small white you need to swap out tips I
don't know what you don't know anything
about cooking what did you go out don't
touch me like that you needed a little
bit of a nudge not what black I see okay
well I have two cookies done this is
super spooky what is that black thing
you're making that's gonna be a skull
are you playing a weird prank on me this
would be rescue because it is this
doesn't work
are you okay all right and I quit it
doesn't work when I think of spooky I
think like a dark color so here's some
brown sprinkles
thank you they make a green monster
gonna make Slimer how many looks like
though who I'm gonna make a snake I just
decided this is a snake now I thought
you well that looks like something Maddy
would produce when he's not feeling well
[Music]
this is what Dexter cookie looks good
yeah I would try to do like a reverse
but this just looks horrible I thought
next time you invite me over
you have better utensils and better
icing that looks so stupid
I can turn us in to YouTube good call Oh
play button what did I just drop yeah so
for this one this is going to be the
grand finale this is gonna be it's gonna
be hmm oh no emoji that is honestly oh
shoot that is an incredible turd look
look I accidentally just oh yeah yeah
he's gonna milk
oh that looks actually like poop I did
not win this competition only my
goodness I've got a snake I've got a
blood bath I've got a pumpkin I've got a
valve ants that looks actually cool are
you making a 3d pumpkin oh yeah it's
here let me make you a little don't even
I was gonna make you a stem think about
it you gotta back off lady oh boy Wow
Wow well I'm done with my cookies it
took me 20 minutes to figure out how to
use these stupid things
oh that's my see what you're doing
alright guys here's our cookies now it's
up to you to decide who made the better
overall plate of cookies clearly you
this spot dusting that's really really
good so pick your favorite cookie as
well
and let us know which you think so who
was the overall winner and which cookie
is your favorite look pretty good yeah
pumpkin looks you know fine Frankenstein
with blue eyes hmm
well thank you guys so much for watching
be sure to go check out Jenna's channel
and if you want to try any of these
amazing cookies are they edible oh yeah
of course they're edible should we try
it
I'm trying to snake your very first two
sometimes Alexa some zombie how well
cancel why I'll see you guys in the next
video
happy holidays American Osama Christians
oh yeah
oh God dying and you have a camera I
think I just follow Oh crisp Oh cookie
Oh God happy Halloween I'm good let that
do whatever it is gonna do
hopefully melt we're gonna ice up our
little cupcakes you're also gonna need a
little cone you need a pointy cone
because this is gonna be our witches
hatch you need some icing you can get
whatever kind we chose cream cheese
you're also gonna need some little cup